17th of March 2023 the international
criminal court has issued two warrants
of arrest in the Eucharist situation
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and formerial
vovabelova commissioner of the Russian
presidents from children's right for the
alleged war crimes of deportation of
children from Ukrainian occupied
territories into the Russia Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories children enjoy special
protection under the Geneva Convention
the contents of the worlds are secret in
order to protect victims the ICC
attaches great importance to the
protection of victims especially
children
nevertheless the judges of The Chamber
are dealing with this case decided to
make the existence of the world's public
in the interests of justice and to
prevent the commission of future crimes
this is an important moment in the
process of Justice before the ICC the
judges have revealed the information and
evidence submitted by the prosecutor and
determined that there are credible
allegations against these persons for
the alleged crimes
the ICC is doing its part of work
as a court of law the judges issued
arrest warrants the execution depends on
International cooperation